Who's that lady in front of our door?
That'll be your grandmother.
Holy...
It's a MacBook, darling.
What are you doing here?
You are denying the girl her potential.
How many seven-year-olds are doing advanced calculus?
You forgot the negative sign on the exponent.
Mary, why didn't you say anything?
Hank says I'm not supposed to correct older people.
Nobody likes a smart-ass.
We petition the court to grant my client full custody of the child.
No!
You're gonna take that girl.
You're gonna loan her out to some think tank where she can talk nontrivial zeros...
...with a bunch of old Russian guys for the rest of her life.
And you'd bury her under a rock.
Evelyn, stop!
I'm raising her how I believe Diane would have wanted.
If anybody takes that baby away, I'll smother you in your sleep.
My sister wanted Mary to be a kid.
She wanted her to have friends and to be happy.
Tell us, do you have health insurance?
No.
Did you spend the night in jail?
Objection!
What's your greatest fear?
That I'll ruin Mary's life.
Mary!
She's bossy.
I've heard that.
He's a good person.
He wanted me before I was smart.